[Music]  Paris and Nicky Hilton talk wedding  planning and babies I have baby fever ET  spoke with the famous sisters at the  Black Panther screaming in NYC on  Tuesday where they opened up about  planning Paris's big day with fiance  Chris Zylka amazing I'm finally looking  for my wedding dress so Nikki and I have  fittings this week yes and she has such  beautiful taste but I can't make the  wedding dress without my maid of honor  I'm loving it I'm most excited for the  bachelorette party planning it Nikki  also gushed over her eight week old  daughter Teddy she shared the first  photo of her baby girl to Instagram on  Monday she's good she's very teeny Paris  revealed her little sis is making her  want to start a little family of her own  I have baby fever and also gives me hope  because I know she has amazing genes it  runs in the family  so I'm not gonna have to worry  [Music]